so yeah how much fun did you have in
vegas
i had fun man i gotta i gotta be honest
though the slots tore me a new one dude
yeah oh yeah they were
not kinda would you play my my one my
slot
what is it larry the larry oh yeah
larry took it oh my god he taketh he did
not give it this time
someone i think they tweeted at me or i
think they
commented on the patreon they said i
played
wheel of fortune and you were [ __ ]
lying it took me for 161 dollars
vanna taketh man that's what i'm saying
they give us but they take it yeah which
makes the giveth
feel way better yeah when it finally
happens didn't happen to me this weekend
so answer this did you get to the point
where you were just hitting to feel the
rush
for the potential win what do you mean
like it was beyond wanting to win it was
just like i need i need that vibe of
almost winning yeah we just were like i
want to get back to that
that zone you know like one the one time
you have a great slot session
and it's like you can't [ __ ] lose
yeah or actually any gambling
yeah you know when you're on a hot
streak it never [ __ ] happens when it
finally happens
you remember that forever and you it's
like you're chasing the dragon you
always want to get back there you know
when you're in a casino and you think
you're winning
yeah no but you do know yeah yeah like
this is what i was going to tell you uh
one night we came back from the club and
we were
like let's hit the crap stable i was
like i don't know how to play craps i've
tried to learn like six times every
single time i try to learn it's 5 30 a.m
and i can't
[ __ ] get it like every time i sit
down they're like oh it's a pass line
and you do a come bet and i'm like
that's funny yeah
come here yeah literally so i get caught
up on the comeback every time
and i can't focus on what the what's
actually happening there's a comeback
come back yeah don't come back i'm going
to come back
he's going to come back come on what if
i just just kidding just kidding i would
i would never i would never
but my i might just slip me
i might put a little on the table now
that's disgusting that's that's
literally a felony i'm sorry
could be worse than his vegas point and
get forcibly removed from the casino
yeah
well i was just joking he said come back
i was coming
to bed i was coming back to come back
you don't understand no come on don't
squeeze me tighter
what are you doing what's with the cuffs
you're trying to make a combat too right
now
stop stop i'm playing i'm playing dude
you're gonna gag me
i'm next please pull them harder pull
them harder pull them harder make them
tighter
make them tighter what if i call your
daddy i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding please send me to my
room
taking my room taking my room we can
make [ __ ] bets all night rip my arms off
oh i will kill if you rip my arms off to
make me 25 again
so yeah so yeah so you're playing craps
so i go downstairs my buddy's like i'm
i'll teach you craps i'll teach you how
to play and i was like let's go
so we go downstairs and he just doesn't
even bother explaining at all he just
starts hitting
i've never seen anything like that in my
life i started with and i'm just sitting
there i'm betting whatever he's telling
me to bet
i started with it with this you know how
those like chip chip like holders on the
table so i started with a stack like
this big i
ended with like i was up like 2 000
or something like that like he was
hitting every single time to the point
where people in the casino were cheering
yeah i mean he'd hit and then walk
around be like are you entertained and
everyone would just start cheering
damn and i was just getting rich yeah
and it was incredible i've never seen
anything like that
next night lost it all same way playing
crafts
yeah when you get with a good craps
player if there is such a thing or
someone like that it's messed up oh my
god it's
so much fun elena's brother-in-law
that dude has wild stories of just
you'll be on the way to the buffet and
he's like oh crash table give me one
second
i just come back like yeah 600 bucks
you're like what what
yeah just this just that just that yeah
i'm just hitting the grass still real
quick
hey we have dinner yeah how yeah
how how do you play this yeah what are
literally what are the rules
there's a comeback
sorry i missed all the other things the
pass line i
i hate when you ask because they're like
see it's really simple so you
you want to bet down here or over here
yeah and if he hits a two or a seven or
a nine then
and then his daughter's gonna come over
that's what it's like every time
and then what this daughter is gonna
show up from her dance recital
if he hits an eight a 12 or a 19 that's
not real because that's not on the dice
i'm messing with you
anyways if it's a 8 or a 12 then this
guy's gonna hit a smorgasbord nice yeah
and then the dice switches over this
other guy who will blow on it and have
his friend blow on it
who will throw it and then you know what
it's like you bet here and then they're
like well then you got to put a bet
right behind it
on the table where there is no markings
yeah like what is that rule
why do i why are there two bets like
this well because you have to put in
them
yeah that's inside yeah
everyone's like throw it throw it
why did i take those mushrooms yeah
just rip your [ __ ] arms off now dude
just do it yeah but it was fun though it
was vegas is very very back
busiest i've ever seen it there was like
at any time that
anyone would want food which in vegas is
every every hour during the day
the line for every restaurant in the in
the cosmo was like
five i couldn't believe the line for
[ __ ] egg [ __ ] egg [ __ ] is not that
good
it's really not there was 200 people the
line
went all the way what took your voice of
a few decibels there
sorry it's not that [ __ ] good not
that good i don't understand
no yeah it's all right it's fine it's
cool
yeah i'm certainly not a [ __ ] for that
restaurant
i'm certainly not the line was around
the corner
and then it had to go through the lobby
so they broke it up and they had a
security guy there
to send people over the lobby when there
was enough room no hell no
like it was ridiculous yeah that was
like
we went to vegas uh one year when shake
shack had opened up there
we're like oh is it shake shake should
be good it was the same thing i was like
i can't believe i'm standing in this
150 person line for a cheeseburger yeah
this is stupid
and sam is like so did you eat it all
what
did you eat anything yeah dude we ate
momofuku oh yeah
we went to catch we went to beauty and
essex we hit some like good restaurants
yeah but um what's so funny sam's like
obsessed with this place called bobby's
burger palace
just on the strips like not even part of
a hotel or anything like that
it's like a [ __ ] to get to to get to a
place on the strip it's like you have to
either have to walk and it's like 120
degrees outside or you have to take a
cab
like around the strip and then somehow
pull up in front of it and then he
screams at you to get out then you have
to hop over
like shrubbery yes to get to the
sidewalk and
play frog earth amongst like 5 000
people with
tall margaritas yeah you know and then
you know drunk people with no shoes
yeah who are four hotels away from their
hotel yeah
well i think it's that way
i think it's that way yeah you're like
dude you're gonna have a heat stroke
yeah drink some water
it really is just an absurd place so it
was happening was it out of there
was bobby's burger we never went oh i
went one time with him like two years
ago and it was like decent
it's just weird sam gets like obsessed
with these places random places
yeah nice good good for him but it was
fun how was your weekend
the the boy carrington from love island
stop dude yeah tell me about that man
he literally was just how funny it takes
me like you guys hung out with
carrington
i was like that's random as [ __ ] we just
we just like
stood there for 30 minutes because
there's nowhere to go
yeah like you came inside my place relax
relax guys is hame inside your place no
come on do you do a combat
you did a combat inside your place yeah
as soon as his boy they
they went inside my place and did he
sniff your tunnel
absolutely well it's actually funny you
say that because to get around my place
right now you have to
go through these plastic zippers it's
basically like
breaking through a high school football
banner that goes into any room [ __ ] yeah
you're just like i'm here uh
so it's you know i kind of do have a
tunnel so i kept
i kept the tunnel encrypted yeah zero
sniffing okay
here's the other part my kitchen is
completely
bagged off with a tarp gotcha so i have
to go through
a little tunnel to get any water
anything anything out of the fridge okay
i've just given up on eating right
uh so yeah anyway we go
into like my backyard area and it's just
covered in stones and wood and other
[ __ ] and we find the four places to
stand and we just stand like in a little
triangle we're like yeah so
so you just stood there stood and talked
about what random stuff
like well how long are you here
you know i saw he was chilling with um
was it johnny yeah and uh who else
like do they all still hang out um
he's he keeps in touch with everyone i
don't know what the relationship is like
between everyone else
okay but i asked him and he's like yeah
i talked to everybody
pretty much um
uh yeah so i think you'll be out in l.a
permanently
around august okay which is you know
this would be cool if you stop by
mm-hmm yeah yeah we'll get them on again
yeah that'd be fun
yeah he uh it's good he's good it was
literally like we just talked about
nothing
and then they left huh he had a few
sentences which i
you know were just very hot guy
sentences
i was laughing at this picture he posted
on a story today yeah look at his
[ __ ] arm
oh yeah yeah how do you even get that
jack the kid is ripped look at this
[ __ ] arm there's like no never mind
it disappeared
that looks like a mat like a mountain
yeah yeah i mean
in person it was really funny you know
i was showing some like he kind of poked
his head in one of the rooms and he saw
some of my workout gear he was like oh
you've been getting gains man you're
probably getting bigger than me
and i laughed and i said what an
[ __ ] thing to say
are you [ __ ] kidding don't [ __ ]
patronize me in what world
parents written jackass in what world
carrington am i gaining more weight than
you
you think i'm [ __ ] stupid do you you
probably think i'm a little b
a b guy right yeah i'm a little peacock
yeah you can't just lie to me you just
tell me
no you're probably getting bigger than
me just the [ __ ] up you hornet
you're a hornet i'm just a bee yeah
[Laughter]
i laughed i didn't even respond to that
that statement yeah
he said that i said oh boy how long are
you here
i love the guy yeah he's a good dude
shout out shout out carrington i gotta
get him back on honestly he's uh
um that man is 23.
he's just doing hot guy [ __ ] he's doing
hot guy stuff you know
i i would tell him stuff you know he'd
say something and i said you know that's
the most hot
guy thing i've heard yeah and i told him
and his friend i said i don't
i don't i don't really like connect with
you guys like that because
your experience in life is so much
different than mine yeah
you know yeah we just went up and they
let us skip the line
the story every time yeah yeah it's
rolled up and honestly it was weird
there's a lot of
let us go i don't want to tell the story
that he told me about
what led to what they were doing that
night but i laughed and i was like
in in no universe did it just involve
like yeah just did
they invited us yeah just being hot and
then this like famous person was like
you guys should you know oh it's your
birthday i'm gonna throw you a little
party like
kind of like that yeah we met pharrell
dapped me up and invited me over and bro
we're gonna hang there was there was
like a you know
someone someone got some free money just
by way of being hot awesome
awesome like literally a stack of cash
oh my god
that's so good so it's like you look at
that you look at the cart girl and it
just
just makes it hard to not want to be hot
we should be hot can we get some work
done
something [ __ ] man i i'll tell you man
karen's doing not fillers or something
you know character would not be where he
uh
he was if he was five seven yeah
it doesn't work you know that's kind of
why
i i always think about should i work
harder at gaining more and more weight
and i'm like no
because i'm just a ripped ass 5.8 yeah
there's a ceiling
just at a point joe rogan that's the
seal yeah
don't talk about joe sorry sorry sorry
did you
ever talk about joe he's not 5'3 he's
literally 5'7
literally 5'7
i got a message this weekend i was like
how dare you speak about joe rogan i saw
that
how dare you criticize joe rogan
negatively you
la elite and i was like i don't know
what your problem is dude i agree with
you i am on
your team what are these what did they
say that
they were like he actually has guests
with like a claim on yeah critical
acclaim people claim on a show
yeah he's like a critical thinker how
dare you
that's crazy part i wasn't daring to
dude i wasn't
um yeah so